thanks to Google meet for sponsoring a
portion of today's video
long have I waited
finally it's my turn
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that always knew that this day
was coming it's been over eight years
but finally the Five Nights at Freddy's
live action feature film is set to hit
the Silver Screen in a little over a
month and you know what that means it
means that nowhere is safe anymore from
FNAF theories don't believe me there's a
FNAF cookbook releasing in October a
FNAF cookbook it's coming for you next
Food Theory now we need is a FNAF
fashion line that's infected all of us
oh my sweet Stars what have I done but
for as satisfying as it is for film
Theory to take another toy out of the
toy box the game theory and claim it as
our own see also Sonic Mario and Last of
Us in this year alone in all seriousness
we are way overdue for a theory breaking
down our predictions for this movie and
believe me there is plenty to talk about
if you're on YouTube and you somehow
missed the phenomenon that is Five
Nights at Freddy's how like genuinely
how I need to know your secrets this
series exploded about a decade ago with
every let's player on the platform
screaming their heads off over the
haunted animatronics hunting us down
down in the ruins of a dilapidated
Pizzeria but while the scare certainly
got us started it's the story that's
kept us going what's helped the series
persist for as long as it has has been
its incredibly mysterious story told
through scraps of information and
obscure environmental details heck 60
episodes later on Game Theory and we are
still trying to decode this thing really
it's only been 60. feels like they've
got to be a hundred at this point and
this new FNAF movie seems to be staying
true to the franchise's roots not in
terms of the lore necessarily but in
terms of the cryptic storytelling there
is a ton of information packed into the
few short minutes of trailer footage
that we've seen so far enough that I
believe we can predict the entire plot
of this new movie right down to the
shocking twist ending that's Gonna Leave
You devastated here's a hint if you
think this movie has itself a happy
ending with everyone smiling and living
happily ever after then clearly you have
not been paying attention so today film
Theory does what game theories never
been able to do solve this franchise and
we're gonna do it before the movie even
releases keep your eyes on your monitors
loyal theorists we're going in so I
think a good place to start with our
prediction here is sort of laying out
what we think the movie's trying to do
with SNAP as a franchise just from
watching these trailers I think it's
clear that this movie does not take
place in the universe of the games why
this thing I have played watched and
read every last scrap of information
this franchise has put out and this is
unlike anything we've ever seen before
clearly it's a murder weapon and clearly
it was made by the franchise's big bad
but why what and how is still a complete
mystery my best guess and again this
one's a guess is that it's a Remnant
extractor a way to ensure murder victims
have the most traumatic awful death
possible so the agony they experience
can be harvested to help create
creatures with eternal life if none of
that meant anything to you strap in El
chippo you're in for a crash course at
the end of this thing you're going to be
talking about Faz goo with the
confidence of a pro looking at the
trailers in IMDb we know that this is
gonna be the story of Mike Schmidt a
security guard from fnaf1 but things are
different this time around well this
certainly appears to take place in the
1990s like the original FNAF game
considering everyone's using old school
wired telephones there are no modern
cars and all the monitors or old CRTs
they're also bringing in characters who
clearly reference later parts of the
franchise specifically Vanessa from
security breach a blonde security guard
in the game who here appears as a blonde
police officer what I think is going on
here from a meta perspective is that the
movie has taken a bunch of stories from
the game franchise and simplifying them
for a general film audience while trying
to keep the most iconic aspects of the
games intact plus they're gonna be
combining ideas and characters from
different areas of the franchise to get
as many recognizable aspects of FNAF
into one film as possible that's why we
see the story from the original FNAF
interacting with someone new from
security breach and then you have a girl
named Abby mixed in there whose name is
literally an anagram a baby all fighting
against an unbroken version of
springtrap that right there that is the
filmmakers trying to bridge the gap
between the different areas of FNAF and
bring in as many fans as they can the
ogs from 2014 the new fans from security
breach and also Your Average Joe's who
can't tell a Fred Bear from a Ned bear
let alone a Glam Rock from a rock star
oh you have so much to learn so all in
all think of this movie as something
that's gonna wipe the Slate clean and
start fresh referencing moments and key
characters from The Game's books but not
being beholden to them because you know
that's not a confusing route to go at
all that said let's just hope they Don't
Stray too far from the games case in
point this detail right here during a
spoopy scary moment in the trailer
Nebraska is spelled out very clearly on
a poster in very large very bold letters
right next to the main character's head
this was an intentional decision
definitely put into the trailers to keep
us talking this means something now the
general consensus is that the FNAF games
normally take place in Utah multiple
spin-off book series have made that
detail quite clear could it be then that
they've moved the setting to Nebraska
for some reason maybe but I don't think
so it'd be weird to just have a state
poster of the state that you're
currently in right above your security
desk my guess is that this poster was
put here intentionally by Mike it's
important to him for some reason my best
guess is that it's hashtag goals an
aspirational place to go to to help him
get out of his current situation because
on the face of it things don't seem to
be going all that great for him it looks
to me like Mike and his family have
fallen on some hard times first off we
don't see his parents in these trailers
at all though Mike's father has been
cast I'm gonna guess that he's only here
for a flashback scene considering it
doesn't look too much older than Mike's
actor Josh Hutcherson additionally we
see that Mike and his little sister Abby
are living in a small house with an
average car and Mike is looking for any
job that he can get I was just calling
to see if that job that you offered was
still available I will take anything we
later see Mike bringing Abby along with
him while he's working implying that
this is probably their only option they
can't afford a babysitter and if there
were parents at home to take care of
Abby why would he be bringing her to his
night shift job so Nebraska might be a
symbolic place of freedom for Mike a
place to escape and finally be free more
or less though I believe that the setup
for the backstory of the FNAF movie is
gonna align with that of the first game
for any Fazbear's pizzeria was a popular
arcade and food chain represented by its
four iconic mascots foxy Bonnie Chica
and Freddie however they're not the only
ones here seems that some of the
children encountered another animatronic
a large yellow bunny rabbit that's
separate from the other four as we see
in a drawing here on the wall from this
shot this was a costume used by the
owner of the establishment William Afton
an outfit that he would use to get
closer to the kids which honestly is
creepier in a movie than it was in the
games you know just your typical yellow
bunny friend holding hands with five
kids which when you're talking in horror
movie speak is code for he killed those
kids stuffed them into suits and
eventually turned him into haunted
robots also just to call it out here I
originally thought that there was going
to be something hidden in this wall of
drawings Beyond just the obvious I mean
it is the perfect spot to sneak in
little bits of hidden lore but the more
that we've seen of the wall and other
trailers there doesn't actually seem to
be that much of anything here sadly and
honestly surprisingly considering the
franchise we're talking about speaking
of yellow bunny men the trailers seem
determined to convince us that the
person we expected to play the
franchise's big bad isn't actually
playing the villain despite rumors that
he would be playing a resident earful
murder man William Afton in the trailers
Lillard's character is clearly labeled
as Steve Raglan career counselor but
here's the rub if there's one thing
we've learned here on film Theory over
the past decade it's that trailers can
be manipulated to create mystery or
confused timelines see also morbius and
infinity War just name two key examples
and here I think we're being presented
with the exact same sort of misdirect in
fact I'm almost 100 confident that I can
prove it Beyond A Reasonable Doubt First
Matthew Lillard confirmed that he signed
a three-picture deal to star in more
than one FNAF movie and unless Steve
ragland's a new character that blumhouse
is just really hyped about I expect that
deal was to play Afton however far more
convincingly we have this scene from the
trailer where a young boy is seen
getting kidnapped in the middle of the
woods based on the film's official
website the synopsis reads that Mike is
still quote haunted by the unsolved
disappearance of his younger brother
more than a decade before and we know
based on casting that the brother's name
is Garrett now the actor playing this
kid Garrett is named Lucas Grant hopping
over to Instagram Grant commented on a
post by Matthew Lillard saying that it
was great to work with him and that he's
much nicer than his character now tell
me why would a young actor playing a
kidnapped boy have any reason to
interact with the career counselor he
wouldn't the only way they interact is
if Matthew Lillard Steve Ragland William
Afton call him whatever you want was
kidnapping that kid in other words in
this movie a big final reveal will be
that Matthew Lillard kidnapped Mike's
brother this would actually parallel
some key moments from the original novel
where William Afton acts under a
pseudonym Dave Miller and has the
perfectly normal mundane job of security
guard for an old abandoned Mall a job
that allows him to supervise the comings
and goings around Freddy's that way when
kids start poking around he's able to
hop into the suit get it hop because
he's a rabbit hop into the suit and try
to scare him away just like we see him
doing here and lastly in the novels he
also kidnaps a kid prior to becoming a
crazed serial killer honestly a lot of
the details here line up now before we
start jumping from video to video to
keep tabs on Freddie and the Gang with
more plot predictions let's take a
moment to thank a service that I bet
Mike wishes he had our sponsor for this
portion of today's video Google meets
gotta be honest with you guys when
Google reached out to us wanting to
partner to talk about their video
calling app Google meets I was
definitely surprised weird theories
about spooky movies yet not exactly the
first thing that pops into my head when
I hear the words of video calling app
but hey the more I thought about it the
more it actually makes a lot of sense
see we've been using Google me for all
of our team theorist meetings for years
now basically the entire time we bit a
business we're mostly a remote company
and Google meet is the tool that allows
that to happen it is quite literally a
daily part of my life with no less than
three hours a day being spent on Google
meet it also checks out because meat
slots into so many other services that
we use every day with zero extra effort
on our end Google Docs calendar Gmail
YouTube it just works seamlessly
honestly we have tried other services
and I hate them they are just not as
good meat supports one-on-one calls
obviously but I can also invite hundreds
of participants if I need everyone in
the company as well as all my extended
friends and family to hear my rantings
and ravings about haunted animatronics
it happens more frequently than you
might think I can even share my computer
screen to present my 87 part slide deck
about all the hidden lore that I just
found and here's the kicker friends meat
isn't just for boring business meetings
or theorist corporate mandated fun
nights it also works great for your
everyday life in fact I realize that I
actually use meat for more than you'd
think outside of work as well and I'm
not talking about video calling the
pizzeria to make sure that the bear and
the fox stay put as someone who wants to
keep in touch with my parents and as a
dad who wants my son to have a close
relationship with his grandparents
Google meets incredible we Wrangle Ollie
and call up my folks with super clear
video no matter where we are or what
device we're using sure it works on our
computers and laptops but Google meets
also available for tablets and phones
you can even use it through a web
browser no problem basically any modern
device with an OS is going to be able to
use Google meet in some way or another
in fact if you happen to have an Android
phone like basically everyone on team
theorist does it already comes
pre-installed and integrated into your
contacts and messages and if you have an
iPhone it's super easy to install from
the App Store so please do yourself a
favor and try Google meet today by
clicking the link in the description
below the quality is incredible it's
easy to use what more do you need again
go check out Google meet by clicking on
the link in the description one last big
thank you to Google meet for sponsoring
this portion of the video now let's put
back on our employee uniform forms and
head back out to the pizzeria to figure
out what exactly is going on in Five
Nights at Freddy's so really when we
look at a lot of the clues coming from
these trailers the story is largely what
you'd expect there's a string of
children disappearing from the pizzeria
resulting in Freddy Fazbear's shutting
down judging from both the kids drawing
on the wall and this shot from the
trailer looks like Afton killed five
children as we'd expect from the lore of
the first game our favorite bunny themed
serial killer hid the bodies of the kids
inside the animatronic suits and in so
doing trapped their souls inside the
robots forever and we know that they're
sticking with that specific part of the
lore based on the jump scare here
oh it is so good every time I see it
children's hands popping out of
animatronic mouths not only is it
terrifying it tells us that he
definitely hid the bodies inside there
but now recently people have been poking
around the old abandoned Pizzeria as we
see in the most recent trailer some
small time criminals break in intent on
robbing the place and trashing it up for
fun I believe that that sequence is
probably gonna be the beginning of the
film these characters breaking in before
they're met with a terrible fate to
possessed animatronics come to life and
kill him as their mid-crime not only
showing the audience early on that these
things are terrifying but also creating
a giant problem for Afton who now risks
having more people poking around his old
murder Den hoping to prevent future
break-ins and deeply uncomfortable
questions about his past Afton decides
to hire a security guard to keep an eye
on the place during the night his first
option doesn't exactly work out all that
well but not to be deterred are Plucky
mass murderer tries and tries again
finds someone who'll keep the building
safe enter our main character the movie
Mike Schmidt Mike Will Do Anything For
Cash based on these two shots from the
first trailer here we know that Mike has
a history of working as a security guard
but likely he got carried away in a
previous role resulting in him getting
fired desperate for cash and with no one
willing to hire him Mike takes a job as
the night shift security guard at Freddy
Fazbear's bringing his sister Abby with
him seems like things aren't too strange
starting off though it's certainly
creepy they explore the pizzeria without
much of an issue until of course there's
a knock at the front door Mike goes out
and meets Vanessa police officer with a
strange interest in the building in fact
she seems to know a lot about Freddy's
in the 80s kids went missing the police
searched Freddy's top to bottom they
never found them that's why the place
shut down looks like somebody watched
our complete timeline soon as creepy
occurrences start happening all across
the pizzeria Mike realizes what he's
gotten himself into there are ghost
children possessing giant robots thanks
for the heads up and here's where the
stakes get higher obviously the
animatronics are going to pose a danger
to both Mike and Vanessa but their
well-being isn't going to be the only
thing on the line during this movie
throughout the trailers we see shots of
Abby going off to explore the pizzeria
alone and ultimately hiding from foxy in
the ball pit let's just hope that she
doesn't time travel in all seriousness
though somehow Abby will befriend the
animatronics especially the leader
golden fredbear a character that you'll
notice never appears anywhere except for
in shots with her why does she befriend
them or rather why do the animatronics
choose to befriend Abby well what do
they want they want to make her like
them yep the animatronics want to add
another member to their ranks and that
is going to be the big driving factor
for this movie Mike and Vanessa are
gonna rush to try to solve the mystery
of the kid's disappearance and put their
spirits to rest hopefully with plenty of
time to save Abby the scenes where we
see Mike interacting with the kids
outside the pizzeria I believe that this
is where Mike is trying to put the
pieces together and is speaking to the
spirits in something like his dreams of
course William Afton does not want this
to happen and has to get himself
physically involved discussing himself
in his old springtrap costume and
chasing Mike and Vanessa around in an
attempt to silence them in the big scary
action set pieces Afton will likely
capture and injure Vanessa at some point
considering that we see a yellow rabbit
hand grabbing Vanessa's neck here and
Mike sitting by Vanessa in the hospital
looking concerned so that's the main
setup for what I see happening in the
movie but what about the big twist
there's always got to be some sort of a
big twist and FNAF well I believe that
it comes with identity of some of the
spirits you see we actually get a pretty
good idea of which Spirits possess which
animatronic bodies from this shot in the
trailers it's pretty obviously
telegraphed funnier kid is Bonnie
redhead with pirate claws Foxy the girl
wearing all yellows Chica the boy with
the top hat is Freddy as for the last
kid though well the obvious thought was
that he was going to become the
mysterious golden Freddy I think that's
what I and everyone else assumed when we
saw that first trailer but now I'm not
so sure the fact that this fifth child
in the shot doesn't have a
characteristic explicitly linking him to
an animatronic has to be intentional and
I believe that it was the filmmakers
keeping things ambiguous so he wouldn't
guess their twist I suspect that the
fifth kid here isn't golden Freddy
instead I think it might be the cupcake
yeah I know I get it it sounds
ridiculous but hear me out on this one
in the latest trailer we clearly see
cupcake moving around independently and
attacking someone without chica's Health
my initial gut thought to this well
that's kind of stupid to be honest like
does chica's Soul transfer down into the
cupcake alone for remote attacks leaving
chica Solas for a while now or can a
spirit divide itself and act on
different parts of the character at
different times you know what I'm not
sure I don't have a good answer for it
but I do think that this would open up
an incredibly dark and compelling Twist
on Golden Freddy remember these five
kids who disappeared at Freddy Fazbear's
in the shot aren't the only kids that
have gone missing in the story we still
have ourselves Mike's missing brother
Garrett who we talked about earlier as
the kid in the back of the car likely
being carted away by old Billy Afton up
in front I mean in this franchise it
would be shocking if someone kidnapping
a child wasn't William Afton anyway why
do I think that this is actually the
moment that we see Mike's brother get
kidnapped well again we turn to actor
Lucas Grant and Instagram where we see
this post of him hanging out with
another child actor named Wyatt Parker
Parker even calls Grant his best bro an
interesting choice of words considering
that Parker was cast in the film as
young Mike two twin brothers one who
gets kidnapped almost a one for one
replica of what we see happen in the
Silver Eyes novel so let me ask you what
if Mike's brother is golden Freddy
separate from the tragic at the pizzeria
we can assume that Mike's brother was
kidnapped in one of the earlier parts of
the timeline a time when golden Freddy
would still be in use and in the games
we've long theorized that Mike Schmidt
is in fact Mike Afton son of William
Afton this would also mean that his
little brother was the crying child who
was killed and became one of the spirits
that possessed golden Freddy given the
fact that Mike's father's been cast and
has distinctly not being played by
Matthew Lillard I don't think that's the
exact direction that they're taking for
the movie but taking the core of that
story keeping Mike's brother as golden
Freddy well that would fit with both the
timeline and serve as a devastating
twist to the Casual audience it would
also explain why Abby has spent in so
much time with golden Freddy in the
trailers it's her spending time with the
brother that she never got to know
whether she realizes it or not it could
also explain why golden Freddy retains
blue eyes when all the other
animatronics have red ones the
circumstances of his possession are just
a little bit different and he's
interacting with a family member so
Afton attacks Mike and Vanessa for
getting too close to his secrets and
despite fighting back they ultimately
lose as they're about to die Abby is
able to win over the animatronics and
use them to fight back against Afton
saving them all you'll notice one of The
Oddities of the trailer is the design of
springtrap it is different from what we
see in the games it's cleaner and it's
more put together it has not gone
through all the rotten Decay that we'd
expect from this character I believe
that's exactly how it ends Mike Abby
Vanessa and the animatronics defeat
Afton by trapping him in the walls tying
a bow on the end of this movie while
still leaving him in a position to turn
into the Cade rotten corpse that we all
know and love for the eventual sequel
however all things can't end happily
here I believe there's a good chance
that the animatronics are gonna wind up
getting what they want out of Abby in
the end her name is an anagram of baby
after all an animatronic that first
appeared in FNAF sister location the
team celebrates the defeat of Afton only
for Abby to accidentally stumble into a
clown outfit or maybe get put there by a
vengeful golden Freddy given us our
villain and the problem to solve in the
eventual second movie Saving the girl
from her Eternal ceaseless torment or
maybe that ceaseless torment is just
meant for me who is now tasked with
trying to solve the timeline of this
franchise across multiple channels true
truly the animatronics have taken
another victim but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory
[Music]
foreign